Oh your house burned down that's so sad
too bad I was planning on bulldozing it
and putting in my advanced coal mine
anyway it was seriously insane fire
blazes out of control there's more at 11
oh my god will you please shut up about
your Freight already Hey yeah I'm
running late they solved medium-density
streets and I'm getting nowhere it was
such a big I'm paying ridiculously high
taxes for this look at all this traffic
I'm screwed
where's all the shopping I'm sorry are
all of these commercials owners not
bitter well if I were mayor I would zone
commercial all up and down this street
what do you mean angle to sharp no power
I'm moving out out of power I just took
out a bond to upgrade the 15
concentrated solar arrays for you and
I'm still upset about not having power I
want it to overlap so much trash there's
so much garbage too many germs the mayor
went and raised the taxes and right
after he raised them guess what he did
blocked his mayor mansion right next to
my house I can't get a shar-pei he added
the extension the sports and limo car
garages then went mad at the greenhouse
oh look another intersection our mayor
I'm moving out Oh gross a low density
dirt road what do you think we are
peasants Yorkshire are cliffs stop
sending me water hey why don't you put
sending me water I'll take away your
sewage treatment see how you like it
[Music]